こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん前がしたことありますか
僕も前が大好きですどんな人がを今から健とやろうと思うんですけども
正直チェーンがで僕
負ける気しませんというわけで今日はある程度のハンディを背負った状態で全館のバト
でお金に申し込もうと思うんだけどもうその判例としてこちらは準備しました
[音楽]
th
まあ相愛こちらいいえめっまーすっぽ一句これ何がすごいかというとこちらは度だけ
簡単筋肉トレーニングをサポートパッドを貼ることによっている電気刺激カナダに走っ
て1個につき4枚のシートが付いてるつけたらだめだ場所が山とあるのでそこだけ気を
付けて使いましょう
顔と頭とが陰部とか
何もする気ないねそれだけのルールを守ってつけていきましょうこれを全部体に合った
状態で金に割れずに体中にこれを全部貼って前が大会で僕加藤と思います
ではやっていきましょう
[音楽]
ますを全部出し終わりましたというわけでここには25校のいきますた時期があるで一
つ2月4つのタッドがついて25かける読んで俺の体100カ所に石を探すことが可能
でござるござるて私れますなぜ今からこの身体に15カ所にパットを張って勉強を流し
た状態で
全が丘塗装ももちろんばれずになってないと思うよ
[音楽]
ますととりあえず貼っていきますとイゾルデでしょ
やばいんじゃねこれ
まんちゃん知れず
[音楽]
ん
やばいはこれでも5分で使うだけで腹筋シックスパックだよって
はいというわけで感謝こそに編キーが流れるパッドを付けおりました
まあそんな銅山とついているので完璧にハンデをソフトハマー全裸で俺は勝つでヴェン
ゲンをつけていけば
でリモコンがすごい邪魔になるので僕はショルダーバッグを強くたまま戦いま
ax だ
[音楽]
あーやばいみたいだっん
ええええええ
アース後あーでも気持ちいい気持へ
パズルね気持ちですね
ああいいですねー
はーいでいいですねっさあこれぐらいのハンデならあってもいいかなってくらいなん
ですけど
ああすごいねかっ
ていた
頭痛やブルーアース語一語何
うわーっいいなぁやっぱこれぐらいの半値以下ないとねじゃあ
ジョジョへまいりましたんじゃあ
だ
いざ大きいです全部的なので戦っていきます
ではでは作目
娘で
ジャザそんなだけやんかー
や理科大処遇純金んでしょ怖い風月料理からだ
はいおっしゃあ負けたくねぇ
[音楽]
うっショールのバンカーいくぜ
re 3
me
uh
バッハ
voodoo
ですよね
えっで撮ってるパッド付難しい
うんっ
そう
負けちゃった